what would you say your father's legacy
will be
i think he's the mozart of our
generation
i think the way we look back at people
like like mozart and
and beethoven uh
from how far we we are removed from them
you you put that amount of time ahead of
us and i think people will still be
looking back
back at him your dad meant so much to so
many people and you saw the outpouring
of love like
people really felt his passing
um what did that mean to you oh it's
incredible uh
everyone has been it's been such a
monumental amount of positivity
that i've haven't really seen on the
internet before
can we talk about the
[Music]
it's video the moment and you see the
love from your father
how much he loved you what did that mean
to you
to see how much he loved like the love
he just
poured over you he was the most loving
and
positive father uh and i i really wanted
to show that
in the video my editor chuck did a
wonderful job
putting all the clips together in such a
great way the song the video ends with
that message from your dad i'm just
so happy to have you that's my song man
so proud of you i love you so much so
when's that from and tell us the story
around that message
oh gosh he used to leave me messages
like that all the time
that that wasn't really a specific um
there wasn't a specific occasion that
that warranted that voicemail that's
just uh
how loving and amazing he was that he
he said stuff like that all the time and
luckily going through my phone enough i
found
a couple voicemails voicemails that were
wonderful and i thought that one was a
really
great way to cap the video off to really
show people how
loving of a father he was did your dad
ever hear the song
yes he did what did he think oh he loved
it he was
he's very proud he he got to hear all of
my music before he passed and
he would constantly say like best album
of all time
he was he was he was really really proud
and what does that mean to you that he
got to hear it
oh it means the world uh i don't know
what i would do if i if
i i was never able to hear him react to
my music and i'm really blessed that i
was able to
experience that and by the way proceeds
from the song are going to his favorite
charity correct
yeah this is it's going all the proceeds
i'm making sure that
the wonderful teams of people who helped
me put this out uh get paid but
all the proceeds that i would have made
are going to his favorite charity mr
holland's opus which is a wonderful
charity
underprivileged students uh gets
musical instruments and stuff it's a
really great organization
and i'd like to continue that
relationship since my father was very
close with them
hey what did your um what did your mom
think of the video and how was it for
her i know did she live those she's the
only other person
who lived those moments all i had to do
was walk into her house and say hey i
have the video and she started crying
before she even watched it
wow she loves it so much she's she's
watched it countless times she's
actually probably downstairs on the
couch right now watching it how hard was
it in the end
for your father just to you know he was
a really upbeat guy so what was it like
those last few months and then those
last few days it was it was really rough
uh it just he was dealing with so much
and it just it just seems like he never
got a break
things just kept piling on and piling on
the second we would get a win
you know it was you know one step four
or two steps back
but
[Music]
for such a for the worst situation
and experience in my life um uh
it couldn't have gone smoother i was i
was very happy i was able to
spend every second with him that i could
what is the advice or the best advice
your father gave you that you keep with
you each and every day
one of my favorite things he ever told
me that his father told him
was when you're playing music if you
ever make a mistake
do it twice so that way people think you
did it on purpose
i guess it's actually a perfect way to
live life if you ever make a mistake
make it again so people think you're
doing it on purpose all right got to ask
you
will there be a tour in the future and
there have been rumors that you may go
out
and you may replace your dad in the band
oh yeah no
no way that'll never happen uh that's
you you can't have van halen without
eddie van halen it's
it's that's just impossible
and i i think you know a message to to
the van halen fans like
it some things just really suck uh you
know i don't have a dad anymore and i
have to figure out how to process that
and deal with it and i think that's the
process
that van halen fans need to go through
and realize that you can't have
the band anymore without eddie van halen
you know the music will live on forever
and outside of you know maybe archival
releases
down the line that'll take a lot of work
but
outside of that the band you can't have
it without him
awesome what would you say your father's
legacy will be
i think he's the mozart of our
generation
i think the way we look back at people
like like mozart and
and beethoven uh
from how far we we are removed from them
you you put that amount of time ahead of
us and i think people will still be
looking back
back at him the way he not only put the
music together but the way he
could play guitar piano these other
instruments it was like a magic flowed
out of him what was it like to sit up
close personal with that magic
was amazing it just rubbed off on me
because that's all i wanted to do and
that's all i'm gonna
play music